what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 9th of june
welcome to the [__] joint the joint
is brought to you by
draftkings listen nba season is in full
[__] kickoff playoff mode
money is easy to be made right now the
lines are still soft the first round
just [__] finish we're in the second
round you got brooklyn milwaukee you got
[__] utah against the clippers coming
off a big [__]
victory off the mavericks and you got
[__] the sixers playing [__]
atlanta atlanta's already up uh i don't
know if they won last night i got to
check and see i didn't [__] put the
bet in anything last night but
draftkings is [__] solid you
understand me this is the way to go
basketball on your thing [__]
tremendous lines on baseball draftkings
will send you an email every day about a
special they're doing whether this guy's
gonna score the over for a dollar win 55
dollars the casino's great the sports
book is great and i [__] love them so
do me a favor
download the draftking sports book app
right now and pressing code joey and be
ready for the whole week of [__]
basketball playoffs you don't want to
miss this especially tonight we got
tremendous games on i think it's
brooklyn at milwaukee they beat him
already by 30. what do you think is
going to happen to milwaukee who the
[__] knows
you are gonna know once you [__]
download the draftking sports book app
and they also have a fantasy app that'll
rock your [__] world both of
them press code
joey but there's something i gotta tell
you real quick
must be 21 over go get your [__]
skateboard [__] i don't need your
[__] gambling through here you're too
young to be [__] gambling resident
new jersey
[__] indiana
and uh tennessee all right
new customers only restrictions do apply
read the [__] draftkings whole thing
before you sign in and if you have a
gaming problem call 1-800 with it
in [__] indiana
or if uh call 1-800 gambler in indiana
and if you're [__] anywhere call
1-800 get with it but if you don't have
no problems then you shouldn't have no
problems because i'm only doing 25 hours
a [__] game two three nights a week
just to watch the games they're on
[__] tnt just entertain yourself so
again download the draftking sportsbook
app today pressing code joey i'm gonna
make your [__] world this weekend the
joint is also brought to you by my
favorite cbd lion
[__] tremendous do me a favor go to
the cbd lion website and read the third
party lab results learn
of what the [__] is going on with you do
you have anxiety do you have pain what
do you have cbd line will help you
read read up on cbd cbn cby and which
products could help you whether it's the
roller whether it's the cream whether
it's the tape they've got pills they've
got you could smoke it look at this drag
[__] cbd line gives it to you every
other single way
right now you got knee pain ankle pain
get the [__] cream get the tape go to
cbd line right now and press in joey or
church and get 10 percent off i think
it's 20 who the [__] knows take a chance
columbus did and [__] get 20 off your
order delivered right to your house cbd
you don't have to buy it from some
[__] ged [__] recipient at a gas
station and that's it and that's that
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
the joint is here [__] it's a
beautiful
day to be alive it's been a couple great
weeks
uh you know i had a great [__]
weekend i told you guys on monday i went
to an ac dc tribute band [__]
tremendous uh live music for the first
time in 15 months
it was great to [__] see uh
on the day it was ac dc bond scott
on the way out my daughter looks at me
she's like what no back and black i
almost [__] died i go no no no back
in black don't worry about it darling
saturday sunday we swam monday you got
the [__] podcast
and there's a lot of things going on uh
we got a weed brand
we got uncle joey releasing his own
[__] weed brand july 16th
i will keep you guys posted through the
ice cream
cake shop in uh studio [__]
city
uh we got an offer on the [__] book
so i'll be coming to show soon we're
still right we're still on chapter
[__] seven don't don't get all
excited
seven yeah chapter seven so we're
hustling we hustle you know but let's
take a listen this is a long [__]
saga look at me and ryan sickler we've
been at it for a year we're only up to
1987 or some [__] like this so
relax i got a lot of good things nfts
are coming mid month the cups are
running late for my patreon beautiful
people the nfts will be on [__] point
for my patreon beautiful people and
everything is great i had a little
[__] uh breakthrough this week
which we will talk about on [__]
monday um how to practice what i preach
i did smoke a little reefer i've been
smoking a little reefer at night loading
up the pipe
going outside and smoking no more
smoking in the house i made a rule but i
get my little pipe and i go outside and
i take two [__] hits i'm smoking that
am i getting as high as i want i told
you it's going to take another [__]
month another month or two but i will be
ready to smoke with you live july 16th
when my two [__] herbs get released
and then we'll all be [__] partying
but yeah i did [__] get high last
week and it was pretty [__] good i
still gave the edibles a week i went
back on the tea but i just took put two
bags in there now uh i'm feeling better
i keep [__] losing weight i'm working
out like a lunatic i'm getting vitamin d
i'm doing all the things you got to be
doing i'm spending time with my [__]
family
i don't miss la i'm happy here enjoy
it's been [__] great great couple
weeks you guys could see it you guys
have seen the growth on the podcast
this is not a podcast have you seen
grown that we've added stuff or whatever
with this podcast i hope you're learning
that you watched me make a huge
adjustment i was a mess
when i got off that [__] plane and
today i'm still not up to 100 i'm still
not doing stand-up but at least we're
making plans at least we're writing
we're doing different things
it was funny this weekend i did
something that i never thought i'd do
i made up with a brother of mine that i
haven't spoke to in uh 12 years
12 years ago we got into a slight
argument over something stupid and uh
i was hard-headed and i said [__] i'm
never going to talk to that [__]
again
but he was the reason why i moved down
here
because i used to come down here and
visit him
saturday night my wife went to a [__]
concert uh a leonard skinner tribute
and i had the baby and i dropped her off
in my friend's house to go swimming with
their kids and i had to take a ride i
had to go to cvs i ended up by the house
so i drove past the house and i uh
saw that he still lived there the house
was gorgeous
and then i called my sister that night
and i asked him if she had heard from
him and she goes you know he calls from
time to time and
he cries he you know you're his brother
you're the only his other two brothers
died and i'm the only one that's left
and his mother died so
you know me dawg i'm a hard-headed [__]
when i get pissed off hey i get pissed
off at you but uh
i had to practice what i preach on here
and i had to
make somebody's day you know so i went
over there with my daughter
he hugged me he cried he broke down we
both cried and broke down
his name is chrissy fish so he made me
some [__] lobsters he made me some
[__] shrimp i dropped off some
edibles from yesterday
i'm gonna start delivering fish with him
once a week to help him out because he's
getting old
and i like it you know you got to be in
the [__]
hunts point market at 3 30 in the
[__] morning arguing with [__]
italians and and the japanese people
trying to buy sushi it's a [__] blast
when he had the business out of the full
market i used to go over there with him
and deliver we we're done by one we
stopped at a few restaurants
a few supermarkets and we're done by
[__] one o'clock but back down here
he'll drop me off and uh
i think he's gonna give me a couple yard
sticks a day i don't even give a [__]
it's just something to do and i get to
help him out he's 64.
he has a hard time carrying [__] and uh
that's it it felt good man it felt
really good to go over there
and talk to him it's [__] up when we
have a brother or somebody close to us
that
we stopped talking to him or something
stupid
you know it was something stupid it was
it was a ticket or something like that
you know you got a ticket with my car or
something and
i don't know what the [__] happened but
sometimes you just gotta [__] swallow
your pride and be a man and go over
there and i did it and i feel a lot
better for it and that's it and that's
that this weekend we have a guest
he's a great [__] guy i've known him
for 20 years [__] solid new yorker
makes me laugh my ass off i'd like to
welcome you mr robert kelly enjoy
[__]
it's my brother robert kelly looking
good like a [__]
how you doing pal good listen matty you
look depressed all of a sudden
yeah i thought i looked down
uh i'm good i just got back from the gym
i'm a little
get my [__] together
that's nice a nice cigar after the
[__] gym you just work the lungs
[Laughter]
look at you like a [__] old school
cuban look at you
all you need is a wig and you could be a
cuban grandmother
you got to see those cuban grandmothers
light those [__] cigars they don't
give a [__]
just to go outweighs them
yeah
that's good what type of cigar is that
any good this is my favorite cigar on
the planet earth hoyo
uh it's a uh a limited edition 2013
the epicure grand epicure cube
dominicans or cubans cuban okay this is
uh
russell peters [__] sweetest guy in
the world best dude ever i mean i went
to his house
and he handed me a box of my favorite
cigars
[__] crazy who the [__] does that
well he's that's why he's who he is
because uh
he's as
[__] great as a guy as can be you
know that yeah he's as great as king i
mean he's he's [__]
i mean dude that [__] right there
i'll i'll i'll die for you
yeah no that's that's why people are the
way they are with him he called me for a
favor a couple months ago done you know
because i know that he's
that type of [__] he'll just
come through for you how are you rob
kelly
i'm doing good buddy it's good to see
you it's been a long [__] time i'm an
old man now i haven't seen you in 20
[__] years it's been a long [__]
since houston our houston days
with pete
remember do you remember [__] you
know i just saw him
uh a year and a half ago
he came to one of my shows and we hung
out he loved you
he loved me and you that we we ran that
club you and me
the locals used to get pissed they were
like [__] these yankees headline
and we would go down and destroy that
[__] room
so that [__] that room the houston the
last stop the last time
he ran it
i mean he was a [__] nutcase too i
loved him oh my god he would drink those
jagers he would do a bottle of jaeger a
night we were doing over there a bottle
of [__] jaeger we were doing
yeah there was always that moment where
you're [__] [__] with him but
where he looks at you and that [__]
scariness you're like oh [__] he's about
to [__] he's about to cut my head off
with something
he would get [__] up with us
those were some old school that club was
uh they never had another club like that
that do you remember the open mics on
monday they went till two in the morning
and there'd be
300 people in there on a monday night
i yeah i remember i would go to that
club
i would stay extra days me too yeah you
stayed
and i would we would we would hook up
the xbox
at like 2 30 in the morning in the main
room
we'd hook up the xbox and play call of
duty
until like five
and i mean i remember the [__] chicks
were outrageous
outrageous the girls that would come
down to see the shows
texas girls are different man
they're they're very sweet
nice
they're down to down to get funky and
they like to eat which i liked
they'd always be like let's go get some
food and
three in the morning you'd be eating
like some chicken fried steak with eggs
somewhere the first time i played that
club i was a feature for bobby sladen
that's funny
i got in on a wednesday night
i was [__] i needed a line of coke
like you wouldn't [__] believe and i
didn't know nobody in houston
and i'm sitting at the bar thinking
about [__] i'm gonna have to get one
of the door guys to drive me to the hood
and
get some coke and i see this beautiful
girl
and she comes over to me and she goes
are you the comedian yes and she's like
i'm are you cuban we started talking
she's cube and she's colombian i go
listen i don't mean to insult you can
you get a package
and she goes yeah my brother what do you
need and she goes i'm with my date but
i'll drop them off and get you a package
and bring it back i thought she was
bullshitting me
she showed up at the [__] room
remember the old hotel they had that
before the hotel got washed out
houston the best thing about the laptop
was they had a hotel that they put you
at
and willie nelson had stayed there
[__] every great country performer
every jimi hendrix had been there
it was just that type of hotel the doors
didn't lock
all you had to do was go back to that
hotel grab a beer and go out into the
patio and within five minutes somebody
would come to you whether it was five in
the morning
or four in the morning there was always
some lonely person in that hotel
and next thing you know you were in
their room snorting coke
eating ass [__] drinking smoking pot
it was [__] tremendous what a i
missed that club when it closed
i was there i i went there and i middled
for dane
when dane was doing clubs
and i remember at the end of the weekend
he walked up to me he's like [__]
[__] him i want you i want you [__]
back
and i was like well all right he goes
your [__] headline here i'm gonna
bring you back three times a year you're
gonna [__] build up a fan base and
you'll [__] sell this place out
and that's exactly what he did
he built a fan that's what clubs some
clubs suck because they won't give you
the shot
to build a fan base he would bring me
back three times a year
and i would just murder every time and
he built this fan base up around me and
then they just started coming so when i
first went it was good second time it
was great the third time fourth time it
was just [__] sold out lying out the
door and he built that around me as like
one of his
his guys but i never stayed in that
hotel i made him put i like i'm a
boutique guy i like a boutique hotel i
like a little boutique downtown
you know what i mean weird [__] bed a
[__] huge pillow with some weird [__]
on it you know maybe a kooky chair
he used to put us up at the
intercontinental for a while after that
hotel went down because that hotel died
in the flood
right so then he would put you up at the
intercontinental hotel and one night
felipe went down there
and when felipe was [__] crazy like
2004 2005 felipe went down there
and had a party in this room and they
lit the curtains on [__] fire and
[__]
and [__] i get a call from pete on
monday like joey what the [__] is going
on with this kid
he lit the curtains on fire you know it
was it was a tremendous [__] story
and i heard that he was up all night and
he went to the open mic and just leveled
the [__] open mic
pete was like boy he was [__] up
but he went up there and the drugs went
away he just leveled that [__] room
it was such a great room man
it was a great room i gotta actually
i think it's i got the audio somewhere i
snapped one of my you know i i don't
snap too much on snape but i [__]
snapped a couple times
the audio's on the internet somewhere
but i was in there
i did my first album
my first robert kelly live my first cd
i did at that club
pete pete was like [__] it because
nobody would give me a shot he's like
just [__] do it here he put the
cd recorder in there for me
so that i could do my album he went and
paid the [__] money had him hook it
up
and hooked mike the crowd
and i think it was the last night this
little [__] sucker in the front row just
[__] arms bro like it's almost like
he came
to let me know
[__] i don't like you the whole show
and i lost my [__] i got so mad
and snapped so bad that other couples
were leaving like they were like [__]
this i'm out
and i was like screaming i respect you
at least you get up and left because
you're a [__] man this spineless
[__] just sitting there and it's
on on what it's on the audio for uh at
the laptop it was [__] great
rogan taped the cd there and then he
released it there he had a release party
what that's great and the night of the
release party i hid in the back room
and while he was on stage i came out
behind him naked
and he kept talking he didn't know i was
naked i was naked with the cape open
like the
i came out like that
and some chick [__] taped it she
still has it it was online for a while
rogan turns around i started chasing my
dick out it was [__] tremendous the
crowd went nuts i still remember looking
to the back
and people in the back were standing on
their chairs just [__] clapping it's
amazing what happens when you take your
clothes off on the stage
people go [__] nuts
now if i took my i won't be able to pull
that stunt oh no not now
my nut sacks are down to my [__]
knees i take my nuts out now they call
9-1-1
and next you know black lives matter
shows up i'm done you know what i'm
saying
joey i pissed i i pissed the other day
on my nuts
that's how big my nuts are i sat down to
pee because i was too old i can't stand
to pee all the time i gotta sit down in
the morning and just [__] kind of
tuck everything in and lean over a
little bit make sure it's not going
through the the seat and the ball and i
actually pissed on my nuts that's how
big my balls are now well let me tell
you something when i did the knee
surgery the redo
i went to take a [__] one night and i
sat down and i actually
when i went to sit down i picked up my
ass stuck to the toilet seat
and my ball sack went under the toilet
seat and i sat on my ball sack with the
knee surgery
you have no idea the confusion i had you
don't know what to do get up sit down
my dick look like my balls look like a
waffle for like three [__] days they
were flat with the little edges in it
and [__] i had blood in them
you know i didn't piss any blood so i'm
all right but my nuts are [__]
percent balls of steel so that's the
only reason why i didn't [__] bleed
but we're getting that old that you got
to watch i p standing up
i don't even put my dick in the toilet
rob kelly since i'm a kid i think it's
disgusting i want women to suck my dick
and not have bad breath afterwards so i
never put my dick where another man's
dick is i don't want that [__] that's
[__]
i pee in my house sitting down
i have to sit in the morning the first
piss i can't stand up
no i i i i i'm so fat joey that my dick
i want to lose weight just to see my
dick again
because my my my
the bigger you get
the smaller your dick gets
you know what i mean i hear you
i hear you but when i was 418 i was
still slinging dick my dick was still
big and [__] it was just when i did coke
then it would shrivel up like a [__]
you know when i did the knee surgery
they put so many drugs in me
that my dick shrunk all the way in i
couldn't even get the helmet out i had a
pee in a container and i couldn't get
the helmet out and the nurse was holding
the container for me and i'm making eye
contact with her because i don't want to
look down on my dick and then go i saw
joey diaz and all that came out was just
a little pink helmet like a dog there
was no meat to it you know what i'm
saying so i don't need that nice though
back in the day man i used to have a
nice
i remember i used to have a nice piece
i'd have to put it on one side or the
other before i went out at night
and now it's a fight it's just a
nightmare it is and i'm uncircumcised
you got to see what my dick looks like
now it got dark over the years
i used to have a cat in my backyard that
was a siamese but he had black balls and
a black dick
his balls would hang they were just
black and that's me now
i'm white my balls are like that regular
off-skin color you got the rashes the
scratches
you got a birthmark and then my dick
with the uncircumcision it's just dark
it's just like a black dick
that's just dark and it just sits there
with a little
uncircumcised little jew helmet on
and that's my dick now it's like three
inches and that's i'm sorry i'm talking
about my dick but if that's what it is
that's what it is on a wednesday morning
[__] what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do
[__] man
people have no idea and that's why i say
you know you gotta prepare for this [__]
once you start preparing for it it makes
life a lot easier i read that
if you're over 50 the fountain of youth
is lifting [__] weights i was
kickboxing
i was doing jiu jitsu i quit everything
i just lift weights now that's the
fountain of youth that keeps my diabetes
down
i don't have diabetes but i'm just
saying that
it keeps your cortisol levels down all
that [__] i sleep more so i'm in that
gym four [__] days a week i got no
options i just started going back it i
all i do is i do 20 minutes on the
pre-core and then i lift weights that's
all i do because and that's all i can do
i can't do any of that i had a i got a
trainer last year he [__] hurt me
two two sessions in i
pulled my uh calf muscle because he's
trying to get me to like i'm not an mma
fighter i'm not doing ropes and [__]
uh mountain climbers
you're out of your [__] mind i'm done
i go in i walk i do the weights
and then i leave i'm out what do you do
for weights bench
back doors
i do the chest i do the shoulders i do
the tries i do the buys i do the back
and i do the legs so i try to do two
a pop so if i'm going in i'll do
shoulders
and i'll do uh you know like buys or
something like that
and then i'll do chest and back
and then i'll do tries and legs
and i usually go i go i got a gym it's
called anytime fitness it's like really
right down the street from my house it's
open 24 hours a day i go at 12 at night
i go with when i'm up usually i'm up
watching tv
[__] everybody's in bed i'm just
[__] sitting there staring at
something because i'm i'm a maniac i'm
used to just being up all night
you know thinking about [__] life and
all that [__] everybody's sound asleep
at 9 30. uh i'm up so i was like [__] it
i might as well just go to the gym i'll
watch a dumb tv show or youtube at the
gym
and i'll listen to whatever the [__] i'm
gonna listen to there and and lift
weights
because
this is a nightmare it just sucks before
you know look i'm 50 i got a kid
you know i'm not doing it to get laid
anymore i'm not doing it to look good
i'm doing it so my [__] kid
you know
you know has a dad
in around you know 25 30 years you know
i had a kid late you had a kid late too
i had a kid at 42. you know
[__] 50.
you got a kid at 50. yeah that's some
powerful that's the cuban blood yeah
that jizz i'm like theo von's dad i'll
knock you up and i'm 74. i got that
[__] [__] [__] [__] that [__]
they they jerk you off in the casket to
get the last bit of that [__] that
shit's good
i couldn't
when i'm dead they could give me that
one last jerk off and i still [__]
impregnate three women all they gotta do
is take the sperm and throw in that
[__] monkey
and they're done nine months later you
got a joey diaz looking like [__]
ugly monkey looking baby and [__] like
that so
i get irish i got irish italian jizz i'm
done i'm lucky that last i got that last
one that made it up the [__] tube
just staggered into her [__] egg and
fell into it so i'm done my jizz is done
no i'm very lucky i'm happy and i
remember going to the doctor
my friends out in l.a the [__] the
muscle crew was like joey you're over 50
you got to take testosterone
and i started taking it i started going
to a doctor and getting a shot every
week and i ended up in the [__]
hospital giving them a gallon of blood
because
my red blood count had taken over some
[__] and i told my acupuncturist and she
told me right out she goes listen
don't do it
it don't work for cuban people and i'm
like what are you talking about she's
jewish what are you talking about it
works for everybody she goes don't do it
and sure enough
after i came out of the hospital i went
back to the [__] doctor and i told
him what had happened he's like jesus
christ this only happened one other time
to me with a cuban dude about 20 years
ago so much
i don't know so my acupuncturist was
right she was like you don't need it you
you don't need to make testosterone you
knocked your wife up at 50.
that's your [__] testosterone what do
you need to make testosterone get a shot
for i'm like my friends are telling me
that i'll be a lot better off
nothing i'm better off now i take a
little testosterone pill twice a day i
lift weights
you do your little protein drink at
night before you [__] hit the crib
with my potassium pills
and i'm done with magnesium that's what
i've been living off of magnesium and
probiotics
that's what all my friends do do you get
stem cells and testosterone go get this
checked no i
i'm [__] old-schooling it i'm
original superman i'm going to the gym
i'll take a protein shake i'll eat a
banana i'll cut down on the carbs and
i'll walk
i'm going to [__] i ain't doing any
of that [__] ain't growing my hair back
i'm not getting [__] plugs
i'm done i shaved my head at 32 i was
like i'm out
i'm out
good for you
how's the comedy going what are you
thinking so far
i don't know dude it's a weird listen
you know you know we've been
it's hard to get these engines back up
you know i i did it for 28 years
non-stop pretty much every friday and
saturday night
pretty much every night of the week
except for maybe sundays but even
sundays for most of that 28 years
and then to shut it down
for a year
and be home on fridays and saturdays
and to kind of get used to that [__]
because now i got a life
back in the day i had no life it was
just me in some shitty apartment in new
york city
now i got this backyard i got my kid who
i [__] love he's got baseball i got
my wife we have dinner we barbecue you
know all this [__] so
now to get up at four in the morning get
in the car
go to the airport check in get on a
[__] plane go to the [__] thing
open that up you know what i mean get
get to the hotel all that [__] it's
it's like [__] man getting those engines
up and then getting to the club doing
the show two shows
[__] kill me
two shows kill me dude you to work
yourself up to that now you got to do
like a show and a guest set for like a
month
a show and then do a guest set on the
second show i you know bob i tried
and it just wasn't working for me i
tried for about six or seven weeks
i took uh i took off from march 2nd like
everybody else till august
i got on stage with our man rich voss
and florentine at the east hanover mall
where you just performed that
i felt good that night the only thing i
was scared of that a bear was going to
come and drag me out from the [__]
thing into the woods
that's the only fear i had i did good
and then i started doing spots in uncle
vinnie's great club i loved dino
but i just wasn't feeling it i wasn't
feeling it i couldn't write new material
and i hate doing [__] old jokes
you know so i said you know what dino
let me pull the plug let me get my heart
and my soul and my head connected yeah
and i'll come back when i'm [__]
ready you know and i'm like i feel you
dude i feel you yeah it's the new
it's the new like back in the day back a
couple of years ago
i would something would happen this
would go down i'd hold it i'd wait till
the weekday i'd go to the seller i'd
work at work and work it
and then by the end of the week i'd have
a new bit
and i'd be good to go
and it was like that thing was flowing
now
i'm trying to come up with [__] but it's
not
there's something missing like i like i
lost something like i can't
i don't know what the [__] it is but
even on stage i'm like yeah and i'll
start bringing something up and it'll
just go it's like just dies
and i wind up having to go back to a bit
that i know works and then your comic
guilt sets in where you're like [__] man
and then you see these young bucks
coming up behind you that are just you
know hungry little
[__] lions that are right you know
and
you know i
i think i gotta push through it i think
i think what i'm gonna do is try to get
a night where i can go down like
aries is doing iris uh shafir is doing
it
well he's got a night at the stand where
he's like look this is gonna suck
so [__] you i'm just gonna do new stuff
and everybody else is coming up is
[__] off and this isn't a this is
just gonna
suck
until it doesn't suck because you know
what i mean because something went out
like the pilot light went out
with the new stuff
and it's it's it's killing me because
you go on the road and you feel like
[__] because you know you know when you
look out and that guy knows that you i
heard that joke before you know what i
mean you're like [__]
it's it's hard and now very hard it's
true because everybody's doing the
[__] covet [__] too so
we got to get out of that era you know
and the whole world changed too don't
forget that there's certain things you
you know
in your head whether look i don't give a
[__] i don't got a b plan i'm gonna do
what i want say what i want and if i
think it's funny i'm gonna do it but in
the back of your head that is there like
what the [__]
you know
they can't they can't listen uh
unless you got a tv show
or
they can't take nothing from you
they can take your sponsors from you and
the tv [__] show
they can't take what you do with the
time you've put in and they can't take
the microphone from you and if you're
selling tickets these club owners
they'll either scab off an iranian's
head you know that they'll [__] book
you they don't give a [__]
as long as you pack the [__] room
right and go up there and give them 150
you'll always be a great comic and
always have work
people got to get this canceled culture
out of their [__] minds
you know what i'm going straight ahead
whether you cancel me or not i don't
give a [__] right i kidding now you're
right and put them in the [__] trunk
of a car you think i'm worried about
canceled punch [__] you could suck my
[__] dick now at this age i've done
it all you want to come at me now
because 23 years ago some girl sucked my
dick at the comedy store who i'm dear
friends with again now you want to come
at me over something like that and try
to cancel this and go [__] yourself
you know you got no you the reason why
cancer life exists is because people let
themselves get canceled i'll [__] go
out there you see what happened in
israel
and [__] palestine they're out there
throwing rocks that's me on the stage
i'll be out there throwing [__] rocks
you're not canceling me are you israel
are you palestine i'm nobody you know me
i got no fighting the dog why get people
get political on the podcast
you said you was on rocks no i run with
the jews since [__] day one i'm
uncircumcised i'm potential so i'm
holding out for the best offer from the
best temple you know me doug
i'm like the number one draft choice of
the jews they're just holding out to see
who who wants to give me the cup
it is a weird thing though because the
people that are coming back i've noticed
this because i've been in the city a
little bit the the the my age people the
people who own houses
the people who own a fridge
aren't the ones coming back out yet
they're staying home the young
[__] are coming out and they're
you have to kind of shake them the [__]
out of the wokeness because you'll see a
joke and they'll be like oh my god and
it's like it's a [__] joke
not you know loosen the [__] up and
once you
lose once you shake them out of it they
can cut okay i get it you know what i
mean all right i get it but they're so
used to
just
[__] jokes
that they don't have to think about that
it doesn't have to
there's no emotion attached to it it's
just a laugh or an applause like oh that
was smart i ain't into it i just i get
it i'm cool with it it's just not my
thing i i like when somebody's mad at me
on stage me too what do you mean that's
supposed to like
i like when i see
some dude having to check with this
[__] girl every couple of seconds
because she's pissed off because she
hates me i love when a [__]
squirms in his desk over a [__] joke
i love it yeah i love it that you're
this [__] weak that you gotta squirm
over a [__] joke that's the first
thing your mother told
told you you know i'm saying sticks and
stones won't break my bones words would
never have hurt me what the [__] are you
worried about why are you jiggling just
because i said i eat her [__] go [__]
yourself you know then they throw the
religious card at you you all you
religious [__] could suck my
dick you'd all be pedophiles if they let
you so [__] you it's not even that
religious people have better senses of
humor yes they do now then [__] dude
30 years ago the religious people were
the ones you know no rock and roll dirty
jokes
the religious ones have [__] great
senses of humor now it's the it's the
the ones without the religion that don't
believe in god
that you know that believe in [__] uh
all this roll course [__] and the news
is their god you know cnn and [__]
whatever is their god that's what they
believe
they're the ones who suck and uh
having a problem understanding that
these are [__] jokes
and it's it's not you know that's our
job to say something [__] up but i
also like i like when somebody doesn't
like me joey i like
[__] turning them i like getting them
you know what i mean i love you all i
love comedy we do yeah i love it too i
love the fact that i'm like okay you
[__] hate me right now but i'm gonna
get you i'm gonna [__] call you out
i'm gonna let you know that i know what
the [__] you know and i'm gonna keep
going and then i'm gonna make you giggle
and i'm gonna go i got you [__] you you
laughed at my [__] you got it now i
saved you i'm your i saved you sweetie
you're healed
you're nice the interesting one those
are the ones that are great those are
the ones that are really great and they
even tell you after the show
i don't i don't like dirty material but
you [__] were funny or they'll talk
to you i'm the same way i i can't
i'll tell you what
i have i just bumped into a friend of
mine and talked to for 11 years
we pulled up to his house he was in
front of the house i told my wife
before i even opened the door i
guarantee
he calls me a spec
as soon as he sees me he's going to go
what's going on [__]
not two words after i got out of the car
he hugged me he had tears in his eyes
and he's like you spit [__] i
missed you i go what did i tell you
i've been called respect by these north
bergen kids since i moved to north
bergen so it does not bother me at all
it gives me a sense of that they love me
they're cool i got like six of them that
still call me a spike the main one died
and i really missed him like after he
died i really missed him because he
would call me insult me and then call me
a [__] and you know what are you
polishing your meringue shoes and you
know he would do all that [__] but he
didn't know that i laughed at that
right so because i'm so open to racism
towards bad like i laugh you know yeah
i'm very free up on stage with what i
say also so
i'm a little worried about that but it's
not what you're saying comedy it's how
you say it yeah
you know uh
if you say something with a smile on
your face it doesn't hit as much as you
know i could say [__] you
10 million different ways
yeah i mean
that's the my favorite part about comedy
is that i walk on stage
and i'm like what's wrong with your face
and they laugh it's like you i mean let
me die if i i'll be in the middle of my
[__] and i'll just be like i [__]
hate your shirt i just hate it and
his wife will [__] start laughing
because she hates it just the fact that
it's the only thing where you can
acknowledge the absolute truth in the
moment you can say whatever the [__] you
want
and if it's true a lot of the times it's
funny
they'll laugh you know what i mean if
you just walked up to that guy in a
applebee's and i when i hate your
[__] shirt he'd probably want to
fight me he'd probably want to and his
wife would be pissed off like what the
[__] i bought him that shirt you know
what i mean but in a comedy club setting
if you got them
you can say whatever the [__] you want
you know what i mean if they get you and
they understand what your your tempo
you can say whatever the [__] you want
that you know we were talking about the
houston livestock yeah i could say
whatever the [__]
i wanted to in that room
right i got away with more [__] than
anybody in that room
there was only one word
you could not say in that room
that would bring that audience to a halt
and i saw it happen
thank god i'm not political you could
not bring up bush there
why you said something about bush at the
stop it's like you call them mother a
[__] [__]
yeah they would freeze
but if you said something about bush in
austin
they would jump up and down
right so you could see the differences
but that was the only
freedom that houston took from you as a
comic
just don't talk about bush he's our boy
dog
everything else
[__] uh remember they used to have
the gay neighborhood because that club
was in a gay neighborhood yeah yeah yeah
when they had great food they were
[__] great food the pizza was good
the auntie dumpling palace
[__] they had a gay restaurant where
they used to have meatloaf and i would
go in there every day and i would go you
know what i know there's [__] in this
meatloaf that's how they kept it
together but i don't give a [__] if they
dna me right now i got eight different
sperms from eight different like when i
took the 23andme i knew that that
indian blood i had was from [__]
eating that meatloaf at that place in
houston it was so good it [__]
wouldn't break it was i'm telling you
the sperm was the crazy glue in that
[__] thing so
it was a binder
yeah it kept it together it was like the
breadcrumbs
you know what's so funny though what
sucks about comedy now
but there's two things that
it's like
i i don't know how i became a [__]
political pundit
i i don't give a [__] and i don't want
you to know what is up here and i don't
want you to know who i like who i've
what religion all that [__] if i choose
to tell you i tell you i
you don't need to know every [__]
thing about me and i don't need to
[__] sit here
i feel like you have to stand on some
you have to pick some side you have to
let people know where you stand on this
on that on every [__] thing buddy i i
don't do that i tell you if something
happens to me i bring it on stage i
think it's funny it's [__] funny i
don't know why all of a sudden i became
the news for you and if i don't [__]
you know let me tell you about this and
that's when she said that it's wrong i
don't like the news i don't [__]
watch news i've hated news was a
punishment for me when my grandfather
used to punish me he'd make me watch
news and i would sit there and these
[__] and suits would be talking to
other [__] and suits and they've
been arguing since we started this
[__] world i don't [__] need to
deal with that [__] i want to laugh have
a good [__] time and then go get some
food and not [__] die and maybe some
sex every six months for my wife right
but you know all this [__] that we gotta
and the and here's another thing too i
always thought we were like the mob i
thought comics we were like the mafia
you know what i mean
we are sure we don't like them she
doesn't like me [__] her [__] him
but when it came down to it we had each
other
yeah no that's not the case
we had each other's backs and now i feel
like one person ratted
and now everybody [__] rats yeah no
that's that i knew
when the rogan mancia thing went down
that we were in the mafia and it broke
my heart for a while that's why i
stopped going to the store
that was why i stopped going to the
store because
the deal was they banned rogan
and the comics were supposed to meet
outside and do a protest
and that night mitzi found out about it
and said whoever does it
is getting banned from the store and the
comics said [__] rogan
and i go well i won't go down there no
more because they don't have my back
right why would i want to be with people
that don't have my back so it really
hurt me for a while
what did you guys go though
i mean where did you guys do comedy
after that i just uh at that time i
would just open up for joe he was doing
a lot of road work we did improvs
uh when i moved to the valley i started
working out a lot at the haha she was
very good to me the agastino the manager
was very good to me and then
one day tommy left and adam the new
booker called me and he goes i'd love to
get you back in here and i went back
down and
that had to be 2014
that was the week of my colonoscopy
i'll never forget it i did a colonoscopy
and i they called on a friday
and i said let me think about it you
know mitzi was still alive so i still
had tons of love for them
yeah
and i said to myself saturday i go nope
i'm not [__]
going back there [__] them
but that sunday night when i was in a
colonoscopy i couldn't sleep because you
keep [__] all night from that
[__] vitamin juice they give you your
[__] yeah chicken bones the bubble gum
you ate when you're four everything
comes out of your ass that you've eaten
have you had a colonoscopy yeah so
i [__] was sitting there and a movie
came out called being there
with uh
pink the pink panther
the guy that plays the original pink
painting
has a movie called being there
that is in my top five movies and top
fives oh it is brilliant it is one of my
favorite top five one of the most
brilliant movies you ever seen in your
life
when the movie ends
if you're not touched
you need to hang yourself because it's
that beautiful
of a [__] movie i forget the lady's
name that's the star of that movie with
him she's
she's [__] tremendous
but it's a movie that's about god to be
honest it's about god
and a friend of mine
that was her favorite movie and she
passed from cancer
and she was a regular at the store and
she's the one
before she died to tell me to stop doing
blow and i listened to her and i stopped
and i was clean so that movie to me was
like a sign
it's time for you to go back to the
store so
i did the colonoscopy monday morning and
i was at the store tuesday night with a
rotten [__] you know what i'm saying
that's so soft
i love my colonoscopy i love getting all
that [__] out of there
and then the next day that michael
jackson's juice
i mean because i'm sober 35 years i
haven't touched anything since i was 15.
not a drink or a drug so to to go in and
get
a colonoscopy and and you know kind of
get a free pass
you know what i'm saying oh you mean the
little cocktail
no and they gave me that michael jackson
[__]
i woke up
i was like wow
wow
it's [__] great
don't think to me for the knee surgery
my doctor had smoking hot chicks these
spanish girls you know i thought i was
going to go in and [__] have some old
wretched nurse i didn't care if i was
naked i walked in my doctor has two
smoking
hot
nurses
that are assisting on this
and my i mean dude
my my [__]
oh
you know maybe when i was younger i had
a nice [__] now it's just [__]
sorry my dick i knew my dick i was
trying to fluff up before i went in
just to have at least a little piece
i mean
it was a [__] nightmare
nightmare that's something that bumped
me out because the two hot nerves but
everything else was fantastic
that's terrible when you have
a female helping you with something and
you have an embarrass like
i take this testosterone
pill but it makes your pee smell like
[__] debt
like when i'm on it for 30 days it makes
my pee smell horrible
and i'm doing the soprano movie yeah in
september in new york
and i gotta keep pissing but i'm so
nervous from the [__] covid
and the people are yelling at you to put
your mask on to stay away six feet
and i went to piss at one time and my
piss was like splattered from my heart
beating
i guess my psa numbers were high that
day and when i put my dick back in my
shorts like another ounce of piss came
out
so my i could smell the pee all day when
i was sitting there talking to ray
liotta i could smell the pee from my
[__] home dick
in my nose so at the end of the day i
told the wardrobe grugger come here
because she was a good lady i put a 50
in the hand they go listen don't smell
the pants
wash them
don't smell them don't smell the shirt
the bottom of the shirts got that horse
piss on it
it was [__] horrible but
i remember one time i went to the
doctor's office i was 400 pounds robert
kelly
and they put you on a thing to do the
ekg
and it was a small office
and the doctor goes all right get up and
the doctor put his hand out and when i
went to get up
i blew a tremendous fart i'm talking
world-class noise
length that last da
when it gives you that last backfire
from your [__]
let me tell you something everybody just
looked like the chick was hotter than
[__] and everybody just stared at each
other in the doctor's office and i
immediately got up and got in front of
the door so nobody could get out and i
blocked their [__] way and they're
both looking at me making believe they
can't smell this debt and it's pure debt
it smelled like piscataway new jersey it
was [__]
it was [__] horrible do you
understand me
yeah there's nothing worse than hot
chicks
in the doctor's office when i was
younger
i mean when i was younger i used i mean
i was shredded i was [__]
i mean gorgeous i i mean i i went to the
hospital a couple of times
and i got i was like yeah i'll [__]
take my clothes off i used to get naked
like brad pitt
and i actually had a couple a couple
nurses comments
on like my body it was weird
but uh
now it's if i went into i had to get i
had to get a little nugget you know what
i mean my dick had some more wounds from
from being a piece of [__] for a long
time
you know and uh
i had to get my my sh to make you
checked
and it was a [__] hot chick
comes in
she's like put this over your penis
oh my god god damn it i'm trying to get
it big
you know and then she's like
she's like pull it like stretch it and
i'm like gosh
i stretched my dick because it wasn't
big enough for her to try to stretch my
dick out because she had to look at my
dick the doctor comes in he's [__]
ugh it was a nightmare and my dick was
just fighting my dick was like i'm out
i'm gone
just trying to go back in my
my body
i think dicks get scared when they go to
the doctor's office there's some up with
dicks cause my dick shrinks the [__] up
when i go to the doctor's office yeah my
dick goes
only one time when i was i worked at a
jewish camp
i worked at a jewish camp as a lifeguard
for a summer back in the day
and uh i got a rash i got baby rash
on my thigh and the nurse
or the doctor whatever the camp doctor
smoking hot i mean [__] ridiculous
and uh i went in
to
say you know hey i got rash
and she goes well let me see it
and
so i i pulled down my pants and she got
down on her knees
in the doctor's office
to examine
my
my side of my balls
and i just remember
my dick shot straight up in me
and i remember she actually looked up
she went up with it like this and i just
went i'm sorry
she goes it's okay
and it made it even harder and she said
it's okay
and uh she didn't do anything
unfortunately i didn't have the balls to
make that move you know what i mean it
was that second where you're gonna go
you know she she want this you know i
just i pussied out like an [__] one
of the biggest regrets of my life that's
the worst well what doctor gets on her
knees that's like
just give me some cream and tell me to
beat it you don't have to [__] look
at it it's baby rash i was playing
tennis
in old underwear i mean what are you
gonna do she let me see it all right
what do you she wanted it and i [__]
left
and you dropped the [__] ball bobby
kelly god
i can't take it anywhere
yeah now nobody wants to nobody wants no
listen i i've said it for years since i
turned i had my daughter it's been weird
like you go on the road
and girls say stupid things to you and
you like giggle and say yeah whatever
and i'm like you don't understand you
don't want to see my dick right now
i'm 58 this is scaring you this is ptsd
this is you're never gonna survive this
[__] these young girls that think this
is a joke it's like these young girls
that keep pressing charges on marilyn
manson what did you expect
you didn't think he was gonna light your
[__] on fire listen to his [__]
lyrics you [__] [__] well i dated
him and he stuck a candle up my ass
you're lucky you're lucky i would've put
a sailboat up your ass
[__] marilyn manson what are you
[__] nuts
you know you get what you pay for cuck
suckers what did you think was going to
happen these little cute white girls
want to date marilyn manson he ties them
up he puts a ball in their mouth
and then they want to [__] call the
la times what are you
times they crazy help you
if a girl likes me if like if there's a
hot chick that comes up after the show
and she's into me i know there's
something mentally wrong with her yes me
too yeah when they say stupid [__] i'm
like what is she talking about she's
into this like she has a thing
for dudes with tits
and a belly button hernia and dead
toenails you know what i mean that's her
thing
she's into some weird [__]
so if i even get a [__] i'd have to
do it with socks on because if you see
my fungi toenail
terrible you put tea tree oil on them
i did all of it i'm done they're they're
what they are you guys know
all of them
my wife makes me paint them black when
we go on vacation
i painted them this weekend because i
know i was going to the pool i just
painted the clear but they're getting
better it takes a year with the tea tree
oil
but at least my feet don't smell like
[__] lowe's theater no more with the
old popcorn
i would take my shoes off my [__]
fungi toenails and i would grind it
i take the grinder and i grind it and
then i take powder and i would sniff it
and i would put it in like a container
like cocaine and i would throw it at lee
we were doing the podcast tremendous
robert kelly where are you at this
weekend
um i'm at napanock new york at the paper
mill
up in the uh up upstate new york and the
boondocks they got this
awesome club this awesome place called
the paper mill and i'm going to be there
saturday night
and where you at next week
i think next week joey i'm at this gig
i got this gig in key west see that's
what i'm doing i'm booking myself at
clubs that i like
and uh
and like key west
comedy key west so i'm going to comedy
key west the 17th 18th and 19th
and i'm staying the 20th
um which is [__] great and then i'm
going to i mean i'm going to [__]
vegas
i'm gonna go to the comedy works in
vegas i'm doing all these clubs that i
like going to vassani's you do did you
do vasanis yet no where is that ah dude
it's down in florida
uh port charlotte then [__] you
murder [__] great club
place packs out
the [__] fans of the [__]
so i'm only working places i really like
to work
you know you know you know when you're
working work you'll just take a gig and
blah blah blah i don't want to do that
[__] i don't want to put my self-esteem
out there and be [__] up so i'm going
to work places i really like
this guy who does the napa knock thing
he does a bunch of stuff in jersey
to a lot of good places so uh
you know i'm uh i'm looking forward to
it but key west i've never been to key
west you know mike carlton
i know the name
oh you he'd love it the dj the dj right
the radio yeah yeah yeah he's down in
tampa yeah he used to be in chicago
right
no no okay he's there
yeah yeah yeah that is yes he's a great
guy in tampa okay
he's coming down with me we're going to
vacation together okay
i'm going to take my time with stand up
i'm going to see how i feel in the next
month
i assume that i'll be in stage on stage
after the soprano movie comes out
especially in new jersey i'm gonna try
to get a little
residency maybe at the borgata one of
the small rooms or something just to
stay active
because of my daughter i'm not gonna do
weekends no more i'm not traveling
there's too much action here during the
week
i got him and uh i want to just do maybe
friday nights somewhere
one show i'm not doing two shows yet
right i'm gonna i'm gonna go back into
this very slowly i like my life i like
what i'm doing with the girls
and i've already done 30 years of comedy
i got to prove nothing to nobody you
know what i'm saying i just got to be
funny
for an hour and uh get the [__] out of
that
i feel the same way dude i mean i got to
work i got i got to do these gigs
because i'm looking i'm a club comic
that's how i make my money that's my job
that's what we do now that's what we do
that's what we do but i feel you on the
kids stuff man i'm around my kid
as much as i can be around him because i
i [__] love it i love it i love i
love the evolution of all this [__] you
know what i mean i love that i i feel
like i did it right i had a lot of fun
at the beginning of it i worked my [__]
off
i didn't you know for years but i didn't
even know it was work because i loved it
it was my my passion you know i was
banging comedy stand up comedy was my my
chick for a long time me too and now
and now it's like i'm good man i like
being in the backyard the whole world
has changed my whole thing is different
now i was at my kids baseball game had
an umbrella had a big [__] rainbow
umbrella i had my little iced coffee i'm
sitting there screaming
you know [__] yeah my kid who's
playing baseball i'm like this is it i
never thought i'd be this i never
thought that that [__]
would get me [__] high
but now
this is the [__] that's getting me high
is hanging out with the kid barbecue in
the backyard smoking a cigar throwing a
[__] ball to my dog
i mean
i'm loving life right now so bro we both
have had the same lies because we rocked
in the beginning this was everything
to us and then god blessed us with a
wife and a child
and now we have a
uh we have to balance career and family
and it's uh harder than
when we were single you know we were
single you don't give a [__] you get up
at two
you get your dick sucked you get a wart
who gives a [__] you know i'm saying you
give it to somebody else i passed out
warts like a [__] they used to
call me the award whisperer you know
what i'm saying
but bobby kelly i love you [__]
stay in touch
and thank you very much for doing this
and uh i'll come up to the house one day
and we'll sit in the yard and yes we'll
talk some [__] i gotta shoot a movie
this week so i'll be in your neck of the
woods this week
all right come up come up hang out smoke
a bath how far are you from astoria all
right call me how far are you from
astoria [__] 25 30 minutes no 25
minutes maybe i'll see you tomorrow
all right buddy sounds good i love you
i'm going to stay back
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed rob kelly he's a great guy
we had some great [__] laughs couple
giggles sorry i talked about my dick you
don't need that in your life
it's getting uglier by the day but at
least i'm honest with myself i'm not
over here [__] taking dick pics and
putting them on instagram and sending
them to people there is no dick pics of
me there is ball pictures out you people
could all take a picture of my balls
when i did it on the comedy store thing
but there's no dick pics nobody gets a
dick pic from uncle joey that's twenty a
life no parole and i advise you not to
send dick pics you understand me nothing
good could happen from a dick pic they
wanna see your dick they gotta see it
live like a peep show you know what i'm
saying look through a [__] hole and
see it i don't give a [__] how they do
it listen the joint is brought to you
today by cbd lion great [__] cbd i've
been with him
for four or five years they helped me
through the surgery as you can see i
have no tape left i got to call up andy
and uh for him to send me some more tape
and some more melatonin gummies
you know listen if you need cbd in your
life you don't even know if you need cbd
in your life so it all starts by you go
bike to go to cbd line and reading
reading about the symptoms reading about
the cures
reading about the advantages and the
disadvantages of cbd cbn cby and how
they could work for you that's what this
is all about
cbd is growing but there's a lot of
[__] fugazi's out there
this is not you're not buying it from
some [__] guy at a place that you
know doesn't know anything about cbd has
never smoked nothing like this this is
my [__] world and i'm an old man so i
depend on cbd so
if you're looking for a cbd line that's
[__] uh dependable and great and pure
go to cbdline.com right now
preston joey or church
and get 20 off your order you understand
me they got great bath balls they got a
great ointment the gummies i use them at
night to [__] sleep with the
melatonin
they got cbd and capsules like the abx
capsules that get you [__] up i got a
[__] oil i got if you want to smoke
it you could smoke this ebd guys
cbd lion
co joey the joint is also brought to you
by listen this ain't about making
[__] millions this is about
entertaining yourself
picking up 50 bucks if i can make you
200 bucks during a month wouldn't that
be helping you out that's why you got to
download the app over at draftking
sportsbook the best as far as i'm
concerned and it's nba playoffs this is
[__] easy this is [__] easy you
don't go every night
you put fifty dollars down one game no
parlays no teasers no you you have a
hard time walking and chewing bubblegum
you want to pick eight [__] teams
what are you [__] just go with one
team blast that [__]
or go for the over and under it's the
playoffs they gotta play defense like my
uncle dan says they gotta play defense
so you either go over and under or pick
the [__] team but fifty dollars watch
yourself make 97 and you go to bed at
least you got something to do i don't
need for you to become a degenerate i
don't need for you to become a gambling
junkie this is just end to [__]
payment it's legal in new jersey so why
not have a good time i'm not talking
about 500 a game i would never put 500
miles on a [__] game but 25 to watch
it my wife is upstairs i'm down here
jumping up and down with the [__] i'm
over here doing the wave by myself you
know what are you gonna do no mask on i
lit the mask so that's it do me a favor
download the draftkings we got great
[__] games tonight i think you got
[__] the clippers against [__]
utah
you got [__] uh the series are
great you got atlanta philadelphia you
got brooklyn against [__] milwaukee
and that's like owned two two
two old [__] brooklyn killed him at
home by 30 points they had the under
sunday night i [__] should have
better they [__] knew it but i was
too late i was out with the [__] kid
[__] around but anyway download the
draftking sportsbook app right now do
yourself a favor and do me a favor all
right
when you sign up use promo code joey and
you could turn a dollar into a hundred
[__] dollars okay that's code joey
and here's the fine print you got to be
21 older new jersey indiana pa only
new customers only restrictions applied
see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now do you have a gambling problem i
hope not
if you do
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-800 with it but if you ain't got
no [__] problems
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now they also have a fantasy don't
confuse don't get confused that's what i
did i downloaded the fantasy but i ended
up hitting the [__] paul and winning
a thousand bucks i took my [__] money
out and i just kept on the draftking
sports book app download the draftking
sportsbook app and go to work like i
told you if you got a problem [__]
mind your business but if you could just
get away with betting 25 bucks and
having a good time draftkings is for you
plus they have the casino
and that's it and that's that i love you
guys thank you for watching the
[__] uncle joey's joint i hope
you enjoyed robert kelly and i'll see
you [__] tip top magoo
next monday ready to [__] go father's
day week i love you
[Music]